[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance I do not know why Trump
planned to go to Puerto Rico I could not
fathom where he thought he was going to
find his sleazy victory lap photo op
except in a dry well-lit air-conditioned
hangar full of food and water miles from
any devastation but moreover I do not
know why he would go and pretend to care
it is now clear it is inarguable it is
inescapable that he hates the Puerto
Ricans
he spent the weekend making the plight
of the Americans devastated there about
him just as he spent the end of last
week making the plight of an American
community larger than 21 States not
about recovery but about making two
barely concealed threats that rebuilding
Puerto Rico will not take place until
Puerto Rico answers to the banks and
Wall Street as if he were not the
president of the United States but the
president of corporations or the
president of the economy or the
president of money to process that which
cannot be understood an American
president prioritizing himself and the
banks and Wall Street ahead of a dying
American community that's bigger than
Chicago or Philadelphia or Houston and
Dallas
that's nearly Houston and Dallas
combined to begin to conceive of the
mental illness that leads anybody to
think that way
one must examine one sad truth about
Donald Trump and when and where he came
from I was born and grew up in the
metropolitan New York City area 13 years
after Trump was born here and from the
people of his era from his places like
Queens or the Bronx and even the suburbs
the message to us children of the 60s
from him and the other children of the
30s and the 40s was direct and rarely
even hidden the New York City in which
they grew up had been ruined they
insisted by the Puerto Ricans in 1940
there were 61 thousand Puerto Ricans in
New York City by 1968 was 612 thousand
by 1970 it was eight hundred and
seventeen thousand look at the cultural
landmarks from that time the touching
1957 musical West Side Story
is the reimagining of Romeo and Juliet
only Romeo is a member of a white gang
in Manhattan and the men in Juliet's
life are all members of the Puerto Rican
gang the classic movie 12 Angry Men from
the same year carries both a plea
against prejudice against Puerto Ricans
in New York and some of the most
virulent examples of bigoted language
you will ever hear quote look you know
how these people lie says the character
played by Edie begley senior about
Puerto Ricans quote it's born in them
they don't know what the truth is and
let me tell you they don't need any real
big reason to kill someone either they
get drunk they're real big drinkers all
of them and bangs someone's lying in the
gutter nobody's blaming them for it
that's how they are by nature you know
what I mean
violent human life doesn't mean as much
to them as it does to us end quote when
I heard that film dialogue for the first
time as a child I flinched
because I heard language like that in
the suburbs of New York City and in New
York City itself in the 1970s and I
heard it from people adults who
considered themselves liberal and
without prejudice and I heard it in
public in places like Anki Stadium where
adults could hear it said and where to
my horror and shame nobody except my
parents acted like it was wrong except
those other adults didn't even call them
Puerto Ricans that hatred that very
specific very regional very intense
prejudice and bigotry and hatred is what
surrounded Donald Trump as a child
Donald Trump who had clearly already
begun life without human empathy whose
hatred and prejudice towards other
groups has been so evident with such
disastrous consequences with the wall
and the brutality of the ice raids and
charlottesville given his illnesses and
where and when he was raised his
attitude specifically towards Puerto
Rico and Puerto Ricans may be even worse
than all the others
it certainly dub tales with the 2008
interview with Howard Stern recovered
and posted last week by a man named Bill
Frisch lling at the site fact base it
was Trump telling the story of hosting a
$100,000 a table fundraiser the red
cross ball at mar-a-lago
Florida quoting what he told stern a man
about 80 years old very wealthy man a
lot of people didn't like him he fell
off the stage so what happens is this
guy falls off right on his face hits his
head and I thought he died and you know
what I did I said oh my god that's
disgusting and I turned away I couldn't
you know he was right in front of me and
I turned away I didn't want to touch him
he's bleeding all over the place I felt
terrible you know beautiful marble floor
didn't look so good
it changed color became very red I was
saying get that blood cleaned up it's
disgusting
the next day I forgot to call the man to
see he's okay
it's just not my thing and that man
wasn't Puerto Rican Sunday John
Dickerson of CBS asked Speaker Paul Ryan
about Trump and race I do really believe
Ryan said his hearts in the right place
there is no heart
thus for Puerto Rico there is no hope
resist remove peace my book based on
more than 100 of these commentaries will
be available shortly there will also be
an audio version it will be about 20
hours long